[Music]
this week we've got hog hunting pigeon
smuggler and cat color take it away -
funny I like all the animal stolen
especially hog hunting I know you're not
gonna like the first one I was just
hoping the pig was a hunter that's my
world that's a hundred hog it that tape
not a hospital do don't be hot they do
Pig hot right before they rip up roots
they destroy the land they're invasive
their basis
anything could be invasive Chinese
people are invasive why don't we say
[ __ ] about that we are in bass
ultimately it's humans fault for putting
pigs in perfectly they shouldn't be or
they run away and then they turn into
wild pigs how do they distort coral well
on the Big Island they you know they
they're looking for food so they're like
like making the mud go up like that so
when it rains all the mud comes and then
they all extra amount of mud comes and
then they they cover the coral and in
the coral die yeah the ruining the
[ __ ] corals [ __ ] advantage shame the
human just care for too many of them
though you gotta kill them up yeah yeah
they said even if like people were
hunting every single day out there it
only keeps the population control down
to 70% and all the guys into a big
smoker and have a giant BBQ fest you've
got to wipe those pictures out delicious
yeah so Texas lawmakers have approved a
new blog I love Texas law
keep going hunting feral hogs via
hot-air balloon whoa what stuff doesn't
make my ganger in if you just blast them
yeah so they're saying that they are I
like it they already have a lot like
okay hog hunting via helicopter yeah
can't why try to act like a man [ __ ]
like you like killing animals and [ __ ]
you don't yeah about that no I'm with a
hot-air balloon I see this big rainbow
in the sky beautiful I think he woulda
hunt a hogs that are invasive 2084
I'm sorry fish so I'm starting to become
animal killer just that you know I was
an animal killer before but I've been
hearing these stories about Joe in case
you wanted to go fishing and I'm like
hey one day I'm gonna be a [ __ ] fish
murderer or two and I'm gonna eat that
fish I grew up being a fish murderer my
dad taught me how to clean and butcher
and slice it up it's part of nature and
I'm going to do it for nutrition then
you should take on all of nature you
just have to attack the evasive yeah I
only believe in going for the invasive
because they mess up the ecosystem and
pigs reproduce like a [ __ ] sandy
destroy Mexican they take food from
others no there's more Chinese people
because there's a huge hog in Texas that
people I think this might be the same
one where they have like a stink sack to
have to like butcher in a certain way so
it doesn't like it stinky yeah but
apparently supposed to be really really
good but those [ __ ] are big
good you think you can actually kill
like a hog yeah and like dude what's
your mindset
tell who you are is the hog I think
before I couldn't but then now because
I've been cooking more and barbecuing
more like if I'm going to use the whole
animal then it doesn't it's not against
my morals it's the same thing as going
to the butcher shop of bio states but
you're actually doing the dirty work
I don't dare do that it's kind of hard
like I I would still be very weird and
out to sea of pink I cut it out because
I saw I always see it on like Andrew
Zimmern or yeah Bourdain another like
you know in Italy
keep it up a bit a bit one and all the
guts covered on my rule suck it up a
little bit much United mean but I could
do it though I would just come up me
throw up
hahahaha I think it's because I've been
doing it because in biology class were
gutting everything yes God done storks
are done sharks I've done so we've got
all kinds of [ __ ] turtles frogs
goats I've got it all kinds of [ __ ] so I
think like that part of it I view very
scientifically it was just a killing
part that I have to get over but then I
feel like I'm lying to myself if I'm
just buying pork chops and I'm like well
I'm not gonna kill the pig but it's like
yeah that's like being a hypocrite you
can't be eating me and then
at the same time be against it yeah you
got to go through the whole process and
understand how it feels like it's really
awful anyway about fish like that yeah
well they don't look like us mammals
they kind of remind us oh yeah how could
a species
yeah like a fish I you know that's why
most animal activists are only like
talking about mammals they don't talk
about like [ __ ] worms and parasites
and they're not talking about things
like that because they're not cute yeah
so sex is saying like they did have a
law that allowed helicopter hog hunting
but it wasn't very efficient because
every time the helicopter would get near
the Hogs it would scare them though then
that's why this they're passing this hot
air baloon law so so there could be a
silent hunter just floating in the sky
yeah they should do that in criminally
infested areas black and white hot air
balloon keep the scent you can smell
your the gas at all you could see the
big [ __ ] air balloon just lying -
smells like a big ass shadow casts I'm
gonna shoot right back at the whole
thing blue and white then take the
clouds yeah I don't know there's so many
different styles of hog hunting and I
think the craziest one is when you go
with your dogs and then the dogs kind of
like gang up and jump the hog and then
you have to jump up and like stab the
hog in the head yeah just one you think
did it
I don't I don't really like it but if
that's the law like theater shysters
different hunting laws and if you can't
use guns but you can hunt and that's one
of the methods then I don't know when in
Rome you know but I'll just go cremated
why would you do that you're going to
destroy the mean maybe with me yeah
because people that are doing this
they're they're actually going for the
mean well so a lively I just have to go
search for adapters maybe a dart Oh
or you get a grenade put it in a sack of
rice with four eggs soy sauce
so intoxicated immediate fried rice
solid any crazier like an animated bam
diamond alright for our next story there
is this pigeon who's a drug smuggler
I saw Hawaii drug smuggler the multiple
pigeons just one so I have thought of
one and there's only been a report of
one and I told because it likes elegant
shoes yes so and it was caught in Kuwait
little boy this sort of cute tiny little
backpack filled with a hundred and
seventy eight pills and they're saying
that these skills could be ketamine Hong
coming I never knew K came in [ __ ]
pill form
that's [ __ ] genius look at this I
like Ontario's you're so used to human
are they trained pigeons like they know
where to go it is funny it looks like
the pigeon is answering question where
were you uh where are you fly to today
huh no good better hey buddy wait how do
they catch him as I wanted to know Joe
maybe they had bread they just said that
is caught it some white like on the
rooftop of one of these officials like
the customer fish all no it's buddy my
brother has an irrational fear of birds
Oh what what are you laughing at am your
shits [ __ ] stupid to know what right
yeah it's the [ __ ] poorest things and
there's too many holes along that's
pretty common it makes a lot of people
cringe yeah it's actually a scientific
because it supposed to represent disease
yep so it's like a natural human
instinct to get away from it but that's
not gonna butter you Kara side of it I'm
not terrified it depends but I'm not as
bad as most people but there's certain
things if I look at give you mixing legs
you're not scary not like the pit much
good it really grosses me out
it makes me sick okay yeah I know it's
rushing some of those pictures yeah
makes me feel like like uh what's it
called be lily to the lily pad or both
the puppy feeder when the Lotus again
the Lotus oh god I think it's so gross
that doesn't make me
it's the one that they Photoshop like
when they have a hand they put like a
ton of holes that way it's so gross but
my brother is usually the flocking to
the wrong who happens it's like anti air
compressor I mean it's better than being
afraid of butterflies oh who knows my
older sibling your java sibling a friend
of butterflies yeah butterflies I'm like
yeah they're beautiful they are
beautiful they are beautiful but there
was a time that we went camping and she
told me that she was going to go to the
bathroom so I saw her disappear between
like these two bushes soon like not too
long like I just hear a go like burning
through and it all needs a season-low
butterfly just like flapping through
between the bushes and I just see her
like flailing her arms no one but yeah
this is one well there's no peaceful
city like this just a monarch butterfly
are they going to lock the spool up or
what you know I wanted to find out more
yeah I don't know what they're going to
do with the pigeon but they just
mentioned that this isn't the first time
they've caught turkeys a repetitive
offender well nothing seems digit yeah
there are other pigeons where they
actually had like he's all tatted up a
little is little skin of the feet I know
snitch vision this is [ __ ] genius
though because as technology progresses
to have GPS trackers and they have like
those [ __ ] heat goggles and they can
be like oh they're growing weed in that
house but they're now back to base yeah
take it back to the basics they went to
the [ __ ] game of Thrones [ __ ] yeah
troll calls
how the [ __ ] do you teach a bird to go
places
I can't even teach my dog to go
somewhere well there has my session
where pigeons has this like homing
technique they're just like really good
at knowing where home is so that's how
people are able to to train them because
they will always come back I don't what
the hell she has two homes get to go to
the pickup point in the drop-off point
pickup point and drop off yeah I
probably heard smuggling it between the
border of Iraq and COI wasn't even paid
though because that's [ __ ] up yeah
what's his cut Paden
worms yeah you better be eatin like some
night crawlers or something you should
get distracted that's probably how he
got caught you stopped at the park
together that [ __ ] breadcrumbs and a
grandma thing she's a little backpack I
got a cute little backpack
now it's life is a cotton ear that
customs building near the border border
so it was like how do they even catch
this pigeon tip I got uh distracted by a
honey and instead of staying on track yo
show who's that pigeon and we start
talking to them and then the cops off
hey [ __ ] backpacker there's an
undercover pigeon Oh [ __ ] snitch dude
I'm black and white pigeon that's why I
was at the customs place yeah but
there's reporting now in 2011 is
Colombian police they found a pigeon
that was smuggling drugs inside to a
prison but then at this one point when
the pigeon got cause because it couldn't
fly over the wall because if everything
had oh my god poor guy three was like so
exhausted and cocaine and marijuana this
should just stuck to one each I know
this is given in there one yeah they got
three little guy you don't come on I
should have trained the [ __ ]
albatross or some [ __ ]
oh yeah it was like an eight foot
wingspan that's not very inconspicuous
though did you use those long-distance
migratory birds the one that go from
like Canada to like Mexico and [ __ ] it's
a little I've abducted me to see you out
of nowhere what doesn't work he's a
[ __ ] blind be going over the [ __ ]
prison Oh everybody that's sick they'll
have thanked enough's no reason you may
release any letter get the prisoners
because they start shooting at the cops
can we have a look like that of their
feathers oh good okay for our last story
there is this clinic in Dublin that is
looking for a professional cat cuddler
cattle I'm allergic I can't do it what
are the requirements what are the
requirements so it's asked are you a
crazy cat person and loves cat no does
cattitude come naturally to you
have you counted kittens before you go
to sleep no do you see the stray cats in
your locality no does petting cats make
you feel warm and fuzzy damn lonely
[ __ ] questions does to know that damn
I said no to all of ya well I'm sorry
for you oh you're allergic I'm sorry go
[ __ ] get Ike I like that I like to
pet him
you're allergic to yeah but I don't care
are you allergic
ah yeah I am I didn't know until like
the last day I was like taking care of
some cats when I just pet the cat I
rubbed my eyes and it just became really
itchy and I was like I've never had this
before what is this and I just started
seeing highs I'm like oh that's all you
got
tell me we're two cats living in your
home to like the one yeah yeah they're
living in the home for like almost a
year but then like I guess I don't know
what happened but like before I never
really got in a reaction but maybe
that's because I never broke my eyes
after I cutted them but towards the end
so your eyes are allergic to cats yeah
apparently you gotta grab the cat and
just rub it in oh no everyday Russian
good my [ __ ] gets crazy I thought I was
because my brother was taking care of
his Fred's cat because they went on
vacation and I went over to whatever
he's gonna clean out the week long I
should the calendar yeah and then I
panic accident cat was like really like
a dog so it would come up on your lap
actually you'd like rub its belly and
stuff so that all just can't so dope and
as we were getting home my boats we got
home I went to the bathroom I ibrid you
so much swollen shut off so they're like
puffy feels like this and then my
[ __ ] lip liner
my brother was breaking into what the
[ __ ] me benadryl and put my water on the
face I hope you guys make your life that
how much did you get paid to be a cat
cuddler
so they're saying this salary will be
about between twenty thousand euros and
twenty five thousand euros that's pretty
good
a year so it's about $22,000 twenty
eight thousand so is that like a
part-time job just cuddling kitties
cuddling kid knows we're here why do
they want you to cuddle kitties so this
clinic is a cat only clinic it's called
just cat
and so they have a lot of cats [ __ ]
only you know yeah they have a lot of
cats that need affection and attention
and so they're looking for a
professional calculator they're saying
that the ideal candidate would be like a
very very venture his assistant or like
a minister or that I wouldn't want that
I don't like that survey I wouldn't pick
these people because I'm just only going
to create like all these people that are
coming over [ __ ] nuts
[ __ ] that I want no crazy-ass people
coming over well you're looking for like
a veterinary intern or like a nursing
intern like someone that's already gonna
be involved
you got a kid grandma's a mom they're
the most nurturing they don't don't get
let's talk about you don't eat you so
you know what that it was saying I read
about this study that a scientifically
proven that cats your human affection
more than anything else so they did what
I said that's probably fair they
probably earned everything else barely
too though it's just that human dislike
yes it's like ball of yarn
humans yeah cuz the only time my
cousin's cat ever wanted to play a
person to touch him was at night when he
wanted to sleep that cat had nothing no
matter what throughout the date sight
don't touch me what I just really just
had to like [ __ ] it snobby ass boys
today you know I mean I'll add a David
oh my god ah [ __ ] about [ __ ] out my face
[ __ ] then touch me and at nighttime he
comes up sucks doing the purring thing
you feel fantastic
[ __ ] [ __ ] you passed away the
recipes Robert loved you very much
that was a cat named Robert oh yeah
that's what was Luke and fat to the
hella cute this cat was so [ __ ] lazy
I [ __ ] you not I saw this will do this
he was laying on the carpet he was
trying to get to a toy or food I can't
remember at this point but instead of
getting up like a normal animal and
walking over this [ __ ] fat ass you
like this he goes dragon oh my god I was
in tears laughing here is that he didn't
do it once you didn't like five or six
times I just [ __ ] lean in I like fat
cat
robert de castro my cats are so fat a
keg RV i want to going on decay news
fans hope you guys liked that episode
remember to follow our personal social
medias and of course if you want to
watch more videos my and she's nowhere
to go your [ __ ] right up there